this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armories Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and this
week we've got the follow-up to our time
in Rapture by Soaring up to the sky in
the vast world of Colombia in BioShock
Infinite oh I do like murder of Christ
good fun I'd like to be able to do that
in real life someone grows yeah
to attack people specifically absolutely
right let us know what other games or
guns you'd like to see Jonathan break
down and be sure to subscribe for more
Firearms expert reacts as well as videos
from several of our other experts right
over to Jonathan
now this is although stylized pretty
clearly a Mauser c96 sometimes called
the broom handle for
this reason I've chosen it because it
looked quite sort of war war weary and
some nice sort of patina on it and I
don't seemed to fit the game but the
version we have here is the special
edition with gold and decoration on it
so we have a really good collection of
c96s here but don't have any gold plated
or gold damage themed ones unfortunately
so this will have to do but it has the
it has the short barrel it has the full
size frame which is what I'm seeing here
and what I remember playing when I
played this game incidentally I did
write a small book on the c96 if you're
interested
um it's an osprey book so Mouser knew
about detachable magazines of course and
they looked at incorporating into
incorporating one early on in the 20th
century
um didn't do it in the end until the
model 1930 which is the sort of product
improved redesign of the whole family
and it added the push button on the side
of the rest of the frame and a
detachable box magazine but the game
version I mean it has a lot of the lines
are there most of the lines are there
the proportions the the cutout shape of
the ejection Port area the extractor on
top of the bolt is there the way it
operates with the hammer Square section
bolts it's basically all there it's
Rapid Fire It's relatively powerful for
a pistol just as the real thing was
celebrated in its day for penetration
that the 763 by 25 cartridge could
deliver at 10 shots as well 10 shots
when revolvers were still the standard
with six shots so not quite a world beta
but a Trailblazer I think we can say
fits the aesthetic of BioShock Infinite
absolutely perfectly I would have gone
with this as well
they did look at the luga I remember
seeing the concept art for that and they
were looking at a stylized Luger when
they went with the stylized broom handle
and I'm glad that they did as far as
shooting goes in in the virtual version
it pretty much works as it ought to
sites for a bit exaggerated so here
we've got one missing at the front and
we've got a normal height rear sight
quite typical early 20th century or late
19th century sites very very small thing
inside a very very small thing very hard
to be accurate with that unless you're
really taking your time the game sites
are almost the other way they're um
almost like suppressor height they have
a really big
Winchester Buckhorn Style on a rifle
rear sight and a very tall front side
and the big departure I guess is the
lever on the side here which is thumb
operated and it
froze the magazine clear so even with
the detachable magazine broom handles
you have to press the button and pull
out the detachable Magazine with this
thing it's in a way a little bit sci-fi
because you've got a lever you hit and
it Chucks out the magazine so you could
doing like a tactical reload with the
thing on the downside it makes the gun
bulkier a little bit heavier and perhaps
reliability probably not all very
special speculative but um it's nice to
see a broom handle even if it's a sort
of fantasy version
oh
[Music]
now this is relatively unusual because I
don't have to speculate what this
submachine gun is based upon I remember
back in the day playing this and not
really being sure and thinking it was
completely made up well I know better
thanks to the concept art that was
released for the game because there's no
argument over this this is the check
zk383 South machine gun
and what's really really exciting about
about it in terms of well from an art
and a design perspective even if it
might irk the purists amongst us but
this is a parallel reality right so
um is they you can see the design
process they went through turning it
from essentially pretty faithful zk383
so long slim barrel shroud the magazine
actually angles upward so it's an
unusual design in that respect not only
did they make the barrel froud short
Squat and fat change the proportions of
just about everything the rocking
handles still on the left side but it's
higher up it's a more of a early Sten
style knob on there they actually
counted the magazine housing
substantially downwards so they
certainly reverse this Arrangement and
then exaggerated it even more which
gives you more of a field of view I
suppose and it makes it a very
distinctive alternative history sort of
design so I I can't really argue with
that as much as I like my guns to be
historically accurate that's not really
any any need for that in this game and
now the real one has this really quite
unusual bipod Arrangement bipods and
submachine gun are not very common for
obvious reasons this one has one built
in and that didn't make it through to
the final design but I wanted to show
you that this one has a sling on it
which is again is unusual and nice to
have and this is a Venezuelan contract
example so it has the Venezuelan Crest
nice markings it's great condition now
you can you can see if you're still if
you're thinking about how they changed
it so much it's not as Ok 3a3 well as
well as configuration things like the
rear sight base being on top of the
magazine housing which is preserved and
the general sort of appearance is still
there it's almost like a caricature
version the magazine housing in this
very long magazine catch is basically
still the same the short magazine is is
sort of retained in the game it's got a
16 round capacity which looks about
right for how short it is in the game
you probably don't want to be holding it
by the magazine but I think with this
design that would be unlikely to cause
you any any issues
so there are actually two variants of
this gun which I've completely forgotten
generally very similar the sights are
different the cocking handle is
different the rate of fire is noticeably
slower one very strange thing about
about this and I guess it's because the
drum magazine is meant to be a visual
difference rather than a technical
difference but typically drum magazines
are bigger well at least are bigger than
box magazines that's the whole reason
for having them is that they can contain
more rounds but here this variant of the
gun has a smaller capacity despite
having the visibly larger magazine so
that's curious that might actually be a
an error I don't know
[Music]
oh
the good old Winchester 1887 or at least
a parallel version of it
again recognizably the real world
firearm and Suits the sort of retro
futuristic setting very nicely right it
has a long rib down the barrel as you
can see flanned at the front and a sort
of rib part way down a bit of decoration
as well it's kind of it's a little bit
embellished design-wise in a way that
doesn't add any functionality and isn't
purely decorative it's sort of
self-consciously different effects wise
the spread looks pretty massive on this
now it does have a quite a short barrel
what we find in reality with shotguns is
um once the choke is is either removed
or cut off don't try this at home the
length of barrel makes very little
difference to the spread of shots in the
scheme of things it's not proportional
in any means to how much you've cut the
barrel down obviously if you get too
short the pressure drops way low the
pellets May well spread out I'm reminded
of the hot shoes hot dogs and Hand
Grenades gone from the other week let's
not dwell on that
only we're on the rail transport system
and so one hand is
taken up and we're doing a bit of a riff
on the t2 slash John Wayne flip cocking
but we're just flipping the gun forwards
and then back into the hand so we're not
doing the very stylish full sweep now
that's actually quite interesting
because if you don't have the large loop
that allows it to rotate around your
knuckles without breaking your fingers
and you absolutely have to try and
it with one hand then that might well be
how you do it because you could use the
mass of the gun to flip itself forward
and then flick it back into your hand I
don't particularly want to try that I
don't recommend that you do but in a
life or death situation
this might work
[Music]
right we have a revolver here another
great choice for the for the setting a
sort of an old west style well let's be
honest this is meant to be cult Navy
percussion revolver that's why it has
these Notches at the back of the
cylinder
how it works
you put a cap on the back of each of
these nipples in these cutouts and
that's your priming system and then you
load from the front of the cylinder your
propellant and your bullets typically
historically that was done with a paper
or animal skin cartridge and you would
put that in place
position it under the rammer
Ram it down and then cap
do that six times or five times
depending and then add your caps and
then you've got your single action I.E
fire
now I've grabbed this one this is an
1851 Navy model revolver
it's an early type with this enlarged
oval-shaped trigger guard which is a nod
from me toward the really wacky trigger
guard that's on this Bioshock gun now I
didn't even remember that being on the
gun because in first person you don't
see it it just looks more like a cult
Navy now I think it's called a hand
Cannon and it's implied to be or it
feels sort of meaty and Powerful
substantial differences though so the
site that would normally be just a notch
on the hammer has been much enlarged and
located here now we do have percussion
revolvers that have sights mounted here
but this is not one of them the barrel
is hexagonal I think not not octagonal
and it has a weird ejector Rod housing
under the barrel and is a cartridge
revolver we do have cartridge
conversions of the Navy as well as
others they still don't look like this
and they don't would not preserve these
cutouts in the cylinder that are left on
this design quite consciously as a again
a bit of visual interest doesn't quite
make sense it's in terms of neither
being fully cartridge nor is it a
percussion but it looks very cool and I
still like it
easy
[Music]
hey this is a slightly out of proportion
M1 carbine with some metal plates
riveted to it not too wildly different
than the real M1 carbine it's just the
butt stock is huge and really long and
the guys got it under his arm which is
irking my my brain
you'd make well maybe he doesn't know
how to hold a gun it's quite possible
his hand is also clipping through the
the buttstock like it's meant to be a
pistol grip the magazine is also bigger
than it ought to be the front sight hood
is immense and enclosed probably can't
see on this one but it shouldn't be so
what have I pulled out well clearly this
is not an ordinary M1 carbine either
this is a T4 experimental
Forerunner of the M2 carbine which is
the select fire version of the M1 as I'm
sure a lot of you know so instead of the
the knob Shake switch it has this wedge
shape selector switch here and then even
more interesting it's actually fitted
with spirit level grenade sights that
pivot
to allow you to aim your your rifle
grenade and then the fronts
a grenade launcher it's a spigot type
launcher
this is held on by well a spring clip
essentially and it's got numbers for
ranges and it's set you basically
set it at the distance you want so it's
getting less powder burn or more powder
burn depending on where it's where it's
set so that's 500 yards
that's 100 yards so doubly unusual and
even more wacky than Bioshock gun
now in first person view we've got the
true to to at least some variants of the
of the M1
um now I'm seeing the site protectors
they're actually not enclosed they're
just huge they are roughly of the right
pattern there's a very strange
projection on the left side of the
receiver doesn't seem to do anything it
almost looks like it's acting as a stop
for the cocking handle which wouldn't be
needed I don't know it's there it's
there to look cool I think
so our second variant of this rifle and
incidentally the cartridge case is
coming out of this thing look about
right for 30 carbine even though the
magazine looks significantly larger
anyway important thing is this variant
has a weird reflex sight with a sort of
hand-drawn cross on the glass which
seems to be a bit of a fetish of video
game Firearms designers scopes with
hand-drawn reticles even though the rest
of the site is is kind of properly made
probably my only real criticism there
and it has a sort of barrel jacket and
that's because like our T4 prototype I
just showed you this is in fact
automatic
so it's a sort of extended range
submachine gun I guess I really don't
remember this from the game but it was a
long time ago that I played it I'm
gathering from this that it's actually
burst so it's mechanically controlled
burst fire rather than just automatic
and I also realized for the first time
that the weird projection on the left
side of the receiver is on both sides or
at least it is on this and it really
does look like it's there to interface
somehow with a cocking handle as it
comes back
I don't know why
foreign
this is quite a generic bolt action
rifle Mauser action I think we can
safely say that brings to mind the 1903
Springfield maybe it's just the American
America in the sky sort of setting the
front sight and Barrel set up almost
looks like 1917 Enfield the cocking
piece at the back reminds me of the
arasaka so I'd I'd say it's a
non-specific bolt action rifle it's
taking advantage of the Mauser style
receiver to mount a scope over the bore
which looks completely normal really
scope itself is a bit stylized with
needless brass bits on it and it
functions basically like we'd expect as
a as a scope rifle slow rate of fire no
damage uh if I had any criticism of it
in a sort of real world sense the scope
seems very high and it might be a
perspective that makes it seem very high
over the ball because I don't think you
could mount to mount it much lower on
the weapon but it relative to the butt
stock it seems quite high up so it'd be
hard to you kind of want a cheap piece
and I think the stock has a cheek piece
to bring your head up into the III box
of the of the scope
um I also didn't see it didn't seem to
have proper feed lips and distinct model
cartridges in there but the game is a
few years old now
great
now this is a bit of a it reminds me of
Team Fortress or something where the
mechanism and the reload is just sort of
hand waved and you just open it up shove
something in close it as you'll as
you'll reload I like the look of it and
and the way it functions in the game I
also like the whistle of the of the
bombs or grenades or whatever they are
as they fly through the air reminds me
of the um the whiz-bang shells from the
from the first world war or something so
it's a it's a not a very realistic gun
but
still a good gun
s
[Music]
and as with a lot of the other weapons
there's a an alternative faction version
in this case mainly differentiated by
having some pointless strips of red
fabric wrapped around the the barrels
but the overall design is less ornate in
fact the the variant guns have
completely different skins they don't
change the silhouette but they do change
the design in in basically every detail
another gun with a great artistic design
that doesn't make a huge amount of
mechanical sense the overall design is
obviously a Gatling gun but man portable
which wasn't wasn't really a thing it
sort of excessively Clockwork with the
the toothed cogs the breech I think it's
meant to be the breach it's clearly
where the rounds are feeding into
somehow firing the real Gatling has a
solid drum of Steel of metal with bolts
that reciprocate on cam tracks back and
forth and each one is in a slightly
different position as the drum rotates
one of them is in the forward locked
position and it's tripped and fires and
then the next one hits that and then the
next one hits that and the next one hits
that it's like an angle of bolts look it
up it's really fascinating so I'm
suffice to say this doesn't seem to work
that way at all we have what looks like
spindles or plungers that are in line
with each of the barrels the breaches of
the barrels but they don't they don't
move they don't do anything it's got
ammo coming in ammo coming out the whole
bit in the middle is just sort of
glossed over not uncommon certainly not
for a fantasy setting the there's also a
noticeable spool up which is now that's
the case with electric Gatling guns to
do with how they feed with a hand
cranked Gatling gun as soon as you trip
that first barrel and bolt Arrangement
fire a shot well yeah as soon as that
hits hits the firing position it fires
so yeah there's gonna be a slight delay
but I think that I think they're
mirroring the spool up of an electric
Gatling gun with a hand crank when I
don't think it would be so noticeable
but it's still a new it's still very
much a nitpick
all right
okay and this is maybe the most curious
weapon in the game it's a it's a rocket
launcher of sorts with a hand cranked
feed mechanism of some kind I'm not
really sure how it's supposed to work
but I guess the idea is it gives you a
rate of fire without showing a manual
reload which they show for the grenade
launcher albeit you get multiple shots
out of that before you have to do it
yeah it's not the usual arrangement of
grenade launcher rocket launcher it's
its own thing it must be the biggest
departure from from reality in the whole
game though given that your typical
rocket launcher is a simple tube open at
both ends with some sort of firing
mechanism and this is vastly complicated
but no more so than other games that
we've looked at those were the guns of
BioShock Infinite and I know this is
heresy but it's the only BioShock game
that I have actually played so I will
fix that at some point I promise uh
meantime check out our social media
accounts over at Royal armories by the
website or whatever you'd like to do it
and you can of course visit us in real
life and see some some pretty cool
BioShock Infinite e firearms on display
in our first world war Gallery where we
have a case of um experimental stuff so
hope to see you there and if not we'll
see you here next week